how are you great to see you
look at how many
that's nice they think I'm they think
I'm blue if CK that's alright no they've
done so look I know you were nervous
about coming on this show because you
and I are so different but I got to tell
you don't be nervous I love diversity I
love pit I'm the guy who's friends with
Ann Coulter that's right
so no but we uh we're different but I
think all right so I'm I'm clean I'm
married I have five kids I'm Catholic
but we both like prostitutes
now I'm afraid well I don't obviously
you're married you do but Jim you like
prostitutes Jim well I I I like women I
don't like I mean I say anyway I just
watch my wife walking watching at home
going what is he yeah no I don't write
artist but it is so funny that you and I
sort of like cancel each other out on
planet Earth right I mean we it's so
funny that people because I think you're
a terrific comedian thank you how can
two people you think I'm a terrific
comedian I do here's the thing here's
the thing what people don't realize is
that comedians were were weirdos so like
you might have hackling like if Carrot
Top was here we love carrot top we love
carrot top why exactly
it's like comedians weren't just these
right range beings we are and the fact
that I'm married you know even any
comedian when they get married there's
always the other comedians like really
you're gonna do that to a human its
secondary to being a comedian right it's
a comedian and then the Catholic I'm not
gonna know that's all right I you know I
was raised Catholic I was raised
Catholic - look I lived across from a
Catholic Church for 15 years I never
went in it I was agnostic and but it
comes down to I I like to think that I'm
such a horrible person I need to believe
that there's something that will forgive
me
that's gym sweet we gotta hear that I
gotta hit you it's funny I was just
about to say I'm here to save you um you
and I and Gary Johnson gonna get stoned
after the show because because that I
hate to see you in or anybody in that
that state I don't understand that thing
that people do that they have to like
sort of take upon themselves more burden
than life gives you anyway
what people are always apologizing to
god oh god I [ __ ] up I don't dad I did
a shitty thing and of course you made me
exactly the way I am but it's not your
fault yeah look I I get the the
construct of what you're saying but I'm
saying that faith is this incredible
leap that like I can't articulate I
can't defend but it's something Who I am
and if I if I I would be lying if I
would be inauthentic if I said I would
didn't believe it no no and I have many
friends who are people of faith and I
love them equally and and you you walked
the walk I really admire that I mean
like you opened for the Pope I know yeah
y-yeah thank you so I just want to know
when you open for the Pope yeah he was
coming on did you just whisper in his
ear
[ __ ] crud yeah you do know I did
you know the irony is it's like I didn't
even I open for the popemobile
I opened for the car I heat I did a set
and then Sister Sledge performed and
then the popemobile came in and he did a
laugh by the way that was not the only
time as excision I have opened for a car
I was at the Iowa State Fair and I
opened for Kyle Busch's NASCAR it wasn't
Kyle Busch I did 15 minutes and then
they wheeled out his car I opened for
automobiles yeah okay all right well I
once open for Neil's Lofgren so tom top
that uh okay so what about the fact
though that American Catholics they love
the Pope yeah but they don't really do
anything he tells them to do I mean
there is Pope
well it's true there's polling of this
American Catholics overwhelmingly get
divorced masturbate at the same time
have premarital sex have anal sex all
these things that are there for the
first time she's ever heard anal sex
before
oh no she's British yeah
but no here's I mean look it's you know
I am a Catholic American and it's it's
kind of like being a Cubs fan like the
Cubs are doing well this year but any
Cubs fan is just like wow you know it's
not gonna work and great right yeah and
so but I am you know I you know because
I had to adjust to this because I live
most of my peers or are atheists and
most of my adult life I was an agnostic
but you know I am Catholic but then
again I'm an American and and look the
Americans participated in slavery
genocide a lot of horrible things and
I'm still and I believe in democracy and
democracy's done horrible it affect your
vote your your faith no I don't know how
you'd vote for somebody even if they
weren't a person who you thought was a
good religious person no no I don't I
don't wouldn't matter whether they
believed in anything to thing about with
this election I'm for Donald Nam the
least faithful person ever but the funny
thing is is unconvinced I've never met
someone who supports Donald Trump it's
like I've never met them away Matt do
you support Donald Trump go and and the
thing is is like I know people are right
for OHS but you know the thing is it's
like I am from Indiana I'm from a red
state I you know I travel across the
country constantly I don't I mean I see
him on the news but I don't run into
people that are gonna vote for him well
but that's a little bit of living in a
bubble I mean what do you do before and
after the show you probably just go to
your hotel room you're married you don't
do [ __ ] yeah I mean it's I get out I
mean I got a lot of steak
anything you don't we have nothing in
common nothing income but we're falling
in love with their take
you